I think we are over an hour in we're
gonna keep going here I have not looked
at these ones which I always all right
is the sign of a good interview but I
have to look at them because I want to
talk some math stuff that's probably
going to go over my head and some of
these phrases
oh hey are spring of tacular let's start
with the e8 and tits
Royden Thal magic square Wow
I googled that okay tits Freud and ball
very funny to me very strange yeah I was
now a long time nobody ever made the
obvious joke ever
and it's all May all-male group I swear
to God is that say about math people
yeah and humor that we can be trusted
apparently yeah um no all right so I
want to knock out just a couple just
interesting mathematical theories and
and some other stuff and I have a few
here let's start there because I want to
impart some of this because as I said at
the top this is not my department
knowing about this kind of stuff so what
God's name is the e8 and tits Freud and
all magic square you're already looking
around well on an example of something
so you have these you have these uh
origami
very symmetrical origami shapes my
grandma made them so this is living in
three dimensions and we would call its
symmetries a group and the problem is
that there are very strange isolated
sets of symmetries that don't act in
three dimensions but act in very high
dimensions so 5233 the largest of these
strange objects is called ea8 and it
acts in 248 dimensions so it's like the
monolith in 2001 it shows up we have no
knowledge of why it's there the average
human being is never worried about it
because they don't know it exists we
have no idea what its symmetrize it only
seems to symmetrize itself and the tits
Freud and Thal Magic Square is this
collection of symmetries that are
generated by some procedure and it's
almost as if it's a
message from pure design from pure order
and nobody knows what it means and so
this is something that we should be
worrying about this is like you know if
I were running the NSF I would say why
are we not putting money into these four
very strange objects called f-4e 67 and
e8 to try to figure out what they are
telling us we know that they're at the
center of mathematics and then at
another level they're like the
platypuses to mammals they're so
different and so strange that we have
effectively no understanding of them
yeah this is going to maybe sound like a
stupid question but so this is
understood purely at a at a theoretical
level or this is understood at a literal
level like it this idea has been we can
construct them we okay that's that's
what I'm at mathematically but we can't
fit that over here yeah so we can't
build them I can't build you a model
right and we don't know all all
indications are that these should be
absolutely central to mathematics and
maybe even to physics you know a friend
of ours also a rival who lives in Maui
has built a theory of everything around
this this object ehm
we know that the symmetries of our
universe seem to generate all four of
the fundamental forces and so symmetries
and physics are closely intertwined now
the question is does this physics
somehow come out from these very strange
objects so do you start with the most
complicated simple objects of a type and
then try to recover our world or do you
try instead to start with an extremely
simple object and have the complexity of
our world emerge and so these are you
know that I've taken that route trying
to think about physics but these are
things that people should at least know
exist and with your viewer base
hopefully a couple of kids are going to
google these things and say holy crap
yeah and spend the rest of their life
trying to
bring it home for us or they're gonna go
man Dave's looking at him like yet no
frickin clue what do you think nobody
does you're in the same boat as I I mean
all I can picture as you're talking
about this I can understand what you're
saying in a in a certain sense but I am
picturing the monolith from 2001 so it's
the idea of something that is packed
with itself or something I think I so
that's the core everything strange and
with Noah it doesn't come with an
instruction manual right we just thought
we can prove that it's there yeah yes so
for example Plato had these 5 solids and
platonic solids turns out that in
dimension 4 all of them have an analog
but there's a new one that had never
been thought of and wasn't understood
until the 1800s that it existed
mathematically called the 24-cell so
these are these puzzles where you know
if you were a religious minded person
you might think that these are messages
from a creator that have not been
decoded and if you're a different sort
of person you think well these are
undoubtedly structural elements that
have not been tied together with the
major themes of mathematics so probably
they unlock something amazing and if you
were Indiana Jones you would try to find
them but you wouldn't necessarily
beautify it but believe in them right
but prior I think he kind of believed in
a lot of stuff yeah and and so that's
that's one of the things is that it
takes a certain level of confidence to
say I'm going to pursue this because
there's no indication you know what are
you gonna get from the monolith does
that make better toast or you know right
or do you become one with the universe
or nobody understand glass see exactly
you just end up in a bed as an old man
and somewhere beyond desire the sirens
of Titan yeah you mentioned the theory
of everything which was a movie last
year but also is beyond just the movie
when the hell is the theory of
everything
um well it's the source code whatever
we're you and I are talking in something
that I referencing the matrix call the
construct and the construct isn't some
fake computer program is the geometric
underpinnings of what we would call
quantum
field theory in the theory of gravity
and these two theories are known to be
flawed in some sense and so they're not
complete and yet there's no way that we
currently have of having a single
graceful and elegant theory that
particular eise's to both of these that
is what obsesses me which is we are the
artificial intelligence that lives
inside of this differential geometric
construct and our job is to figure out
what is our own source code so we sort
of did this at one level with let's
let's say DNA or the theory of selection
from Darwin so humans have been trying
to figure out progressively okay what is
this place where are we having this
conversation with the Rubin report right
right and the idea it's not just LA it
might be deeper than that oh yeah it
could fever yeah it could be Simi Valley
you don't know but uh I think that what
it is is it's the greatest puzzle ever
this is this is the main story can we
understand each level of our source code
right down to the machine code do you
think we can actually get there well
that's an awkward question because I
think that I'm I'm gambling that I've
broken through something which could
could put me pretty close so let's talk
about that thing all right
this was about three years ago three and
a half well that's it about there yeah I
know your mathematician has to be very
precise so can you explain what you did
about three years ago that clipped some
of I'd Stein's stuff sure so when I was
a a young guy
I watched string theory start to bubble
up in 1984 there was a discovery and
there was a lot of desperation because
for about ten years theoretical physics
had been stalled and I looked at
strength here and I said this is
fascinating
it's really interesting and it doesn't
feel right and I bet the whole field is
going to go down this path at least give
me string theory 101 just for string
theory 101 says the
your concept of the world is not a
theory of waves built on idealized
little balls but instead you imagine
some sort of rubberband like geometric
structures and then you'd build waves in
some sense on top of that rather than on
on point particles and very quickly it
starts to get greedy and it demands I
want to live in 26 dimensions or I want
to live in 10 dimensions maybe 11 I want
to have this super symmetric aspects
which has to do with a symmetry between
force and matter and the problem is is
that it feels intellectually like a
check-kiting scheme where you're
constantly repairing something but
you're opening up a new can of worms and
I don't think that solvent at the moment
that nobody's figured out how to get
this this game to close and to rejoin
what we think of as experimentally
verified physics so I think I was early
saying this is madness and I went into
mathematics in order to avoid what I saw
is like the tulip bubble of string
theory
huh and so what I believed was that
actually the hardest thing is to unthink
Einstein because Einstein laid the
groundwork when we talk about string
theory we still think about space and
time as space-time and there's something
wrong at that level but there's nothing
to correct it's it's so elementary that
it's as if there's no room to fix it
right you'd have to untie a gajillion
other things or so it seems all right
and so what I what I did was I tried to
spot a couple of things that people had
in my opinion miss thunk about the
geometric underpinnings that were there
were some discoveries in the mid-1970s
by Jim Simons the world's most
successful hedge fund manager and CN
yang arguably the greatest living
theoretical physicist where they figured
out a dictionary between mathematics
particularly geometry and theoretical
physics which has spawned a revolution
that is now 40 years old right and so
some of the equations that came out of
that I saw as capable of replacing
Einstein's field equations which are
very elegant and again have this this
feature of locking out any attempt to
play with them so if you think about the
world that we see around us as currently
understood by physics there are three
main equations Einstein field equations
there's the souped-up Maxwell's
equations called yang-mills and then
there's something called the Dirac
equation for matter and those three
equations are in some sense probably the
simplest equations in their classes so
we're a little bit stumped because it
feels like okay there's nowhere to go
we've searched the room for our keys we
cannot find them and we can almost say
that they can't be here but that's not
quite true so the way I saw it is is
that physics conceived of a battle
between Einstein and Bohr relativity and
quantum mechanics and in fact what we
found was is that Einstein was derived
from a kind of geometry called Romani in
geometry and only recently in the 1970s
did we find out that quantum mechanics
seems to come from a different geometry
from a guy named Arish mon-sol era
shmaaya geometry and so what I did is I
said I don't think it's a battle between
Einstein and Bohr I think it's a battle
between Riemann and Arish MA and the
question is is there any geometry known
that can incorporate the advantages of
both of these two different kinds of
geometries and in generically there
isn't but in a very special case you can
marry them and get something new and
when I was in graduate school we thought
there were only 16 particles and what we
call a generation that mostly makes up
this construct but it turned out that
neutrinos had a little bit of mass and
that meant that there was an extra
possible particle from 15 to 16
particles so we thought 15 now 16
and if you have two to the two to the n
particles so in this case two to the
fourth there's a new kind of geometry
that combines arish monte and geometry
and romani and geometry that might
govern our world and so what I believe
is is that physicists have an economic
incentive to study the generic cases
because that's what you can build a
career on but our world may be the most
particular of cases and so it's a sort
of a one-way suicide pact dieter it's
going to work or it isn't right and so I
went to non-economic route which was
sort of self-destructive but that I
lined up Eric I am NOT going to pretend
that I fully understood all of them but
I got some of it okay how about that
that's a start right you gotta start
somewhere it's not I'm doing like
Einstein thing you got to start
somewhere
exactly we'll go from there you know all
right so I got one more for you sure the
edge question we toss a question that
goes out to about it was about 200 tuna
public intellectuals per years public
intellectuals fair to say it's always
kind posers acres and blowhard by - look
yeah yeah this question Jon Brockman
does a beautiful job of assembling some
of the more interesting minds and I
somehow snuck in and I've remained in
every year but one for the last seven or
so years so every year at the end of the
year he sends out this question to all
of these people and he asked them to
respond and then they post all their
answers publicly you were one of the 200
or so people I want to get the question
absolutely right the edge question of
the year of 2016 was what scientific
term or concept should be more widely
known right what was your answer to that
so I deliberated it's very similar to
the question he asked in 2011 what would
improve everyone's cognitive toolkit and
I said professional wrestling and
kayfabe because my wife told me as well
take the risk yeah but so this year you
would have to write about the
professional wrestling's actly as you
explained it with Trump so there you go
in 2017 I chose Russell conjugation and
Russell conjugation
was so we were talking privately before
about the need to push out new language
to understand our world okay I'm glad
you're ending with this I was going to
do a bonus thing so we'll do it we'll do
it right now okay
so the the thing that I I was searching
for was what word should I use that
sounds like synonym where two words are
content synonyms but maybe emotionally
antonyms so a good one is fink and
whistle-blower mm-hmm right and so I
asked this question on Quora and people
said oh it's you know it's loaded speech
no no that's too general finally
somebody I think in Florida wrote in and
said you're looking for a motive
conjugation or Russell conjugation turns
out Bertrand Russell had been here
earlier and in 1948 he was on the BBC
and he said let's look at the
construction I am firm you are obstinate
he she or it is a pigheaded fool and
that that was just a moment where I said
oh my gosh I don't realize that I have
been given no extra information about
the three conjugations that he's gone
through and yet I feel differently I
like the fact that somebody is firm in
steadfast and I dislike the fact that
somebody is pigheaded and then I
realized that this could actually be
weaponized
and as part of an arms race that maybe
the newspapers were in fact conjugating
president strongman dictator mm-hmm and
so I remembered this very strange phrase
from years past Panamanian strongman
Manuel Noriega and I thought who would
come up with a construction that awkward
and always invariant and then everyone
read and everyone uses it exactly
hawkish he's hawkish right or
controversial businessman was was
applied to a friend of mine declan
Ganley who had fought the Lisbon Treaty
in the EU and at some point they removed
controversial businessman so he just
became businessman declan galley and so
what I what I came to understand is is
that the big boys don't play around with
faking the facts what they realized is
that we have multiple opinions on
everything
but our emotional state selects which
opinion and the person who figured this
out it is Frank Luntz and Franklin's is
a Republican pollster there's video of
him where he asks people you know what
do you think about undocumented workers
oh you know they're doing a great job
and we have to recognize the
contribution well do you support illegal
aliens no no they should be deported
yeah and in an instant and then you see
that the mind doesn't see itself it's
having two reactions to death tax in a
state it's the same object and so we are
both for and against everything and so
while we're watching information they're
not looking at information they're
looking at the emotional shading because
our emotions pick out which of our
multiple opinions we're actually going
to act and so what I'm pointing to here
is that this is the language that you
need to get underneath the constructed
world that you're presented with and
what I hope is that this essay is going
to show people that you can code up a
computer program to crawl text with
against the table of Russell conjugates
to figure out what the exact bias is of
any news source I don't need to know
about Breitbart is conservative
let me crawl it let's just look at the
buzzword let's look at the Python
program use regular expressions grab the
text match it against the table and I'll
tell you exactly what you're being told
to feel irrespective you can be trusted
with the knowledge what you can't be
trusted with is your feelings because
the feelings determine the opinion and
so this is the great binary weapon the
information superhighway had very little
effect relative to what we were
expecting because it needs the second
emotional component there's no emotional
superhighway to go next to it this is so
fascinating because it's so everything
that's happening right now and it
actually does maybe this is the unifying
principle of our entire conversation
because it fits within the fake news
thing it fits within the algorithm thing
it fits within trying to talk about talk
about honestly talk honestly
difficult issues I mean it's all it's
all right there well you think about it
like this if if you're going to trust
somebody like a physician to put you
under and operate on you you want to
have a lot of previous discussions so
that you feel that person is aligned
with you
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
get the power tools into the hands of
the people who've not been trusted with
them and to say hey I want to upgrade my
relationship I don't really want to kill
the New York Times
I want the New York Times to learn how
to respect people who are as smart or
smarter than the editors who drive the
narratives then the reporters will go
out and report and I want them to come
to see themselves as part of the problem
and part of the story which is please
stop with the editorial headline
everything's editorialize now right and
stop with the narratives and you're
going to have to be in partnership
because you don't have the gatekeeping
ability anymore and previously we
democratized information but we kept
turning the New York Times please tell
me how to feel those aren't revolutions
in Tahrir Square those are
demonstrations right and so I was the
one who was off of social media I was
saying I'm watching a revolution but in
New York when I went to a party people
would say what are you talking about the
demonstration yeah right and so these
conjugates then they realize that after
Mubarak went down that it was no no this
is the amazing part about it it's only
when you actually hear the authoritative
source that you've empowered right to
switch the language that you actually
feel safe because what happens is if you
just take what you see and then you go
into your social group you will find
that you will be instantly ostracized
and so what we've been we've been
depending on the New York Times not for
information we've been depending upon it
for to tell us what's safe to feel with
whom should I empathize who should I
consider a pariah who should I hug to my
bosom and this is the thing that we're
now going to break through so 2016 was
the year when that started to crumble
yeah so let's just go through a couple
words that wave that we've discussed and
that you've been part of so first off
the word bigoted ear I had Tim Ferriss
on and I think he came up with the
phrase when you were on his pod
yes and basically it was this idea of
what the social justice warriors are
doing is not good they are finding
bigotry everywhere and they are cheering
bigotry because that is the ultimate
virtue signaling goodness what's a
hunting license for people that you
disagree with right you can anybody I
can label a bigot I'm allowed to hunt
yeah so I love the fact that I've been
pushing it out a little bit now and I
see it starting to gain a little
traction so that's one and then one that
you actually came up with on your Sam
Harris's podcast was steel Manning which
I thought was not mine oh that's not you
don't know oh I've given I'm giving you
who know no that comes from sort of the
rationality community that I run with
I'm a huge on attribution I think it's
important oh absolutely I they taught
into me to tribute all right so dude you
know who actually came up with it I
think I first heard it from the first
person I heard use it powerfully was Yan
Tollan who is a brilliant Estonian who
coded up Skype uh-huh and just an
all-around very deep thinker well now I
know you're very honest because I was I
was attributing it to you much as I wish
I could claim credit yeah I know I think
that you know for example one thing I've
been focused on is long short positions
so the idea that your long support for
Muslims and your short support for
Islamists where those things sound very
similar to most people right right but
the idea of pulling apart something
that's good from something that sounds
similar to it but is in fact very
dangerous is something that we are going
to be doing and that's I think one of
the things that we're going to give is
our gift to the dialog how do you hold
these nuanced positions that we've
talked before but there seem to be about
20-25 people who can try to do this in
public without falling off the a frame
roof where they're dancing on
rationality and if you follow this
direction you end up as a troglodyte and
if you end up this direction you end up
with political correctness right so
almost no one can
managed to do this because the forces
are making it impossible so I think that
long short thinking which is taking the
marketplace of ideas and treating it as
we treat market the marketplace of
investment of anything else right yeah
all right I love that I'm going to start
using that let's just backtrack voters
to steel Manning real quick even though
you didn't show up with it but I but I
think it's such an important piece of
what's going on here because we know
that in the public space there are so
many people who do the reverse of that
they strawman this is and steel Manning
is basically laying out your
opposition's ideas in the clearest most
concise way so that you can attack them
properly right I mean that's the idea
you are still Manning their position so
that you can then disassemble it fairly
and honestly as opposed to what we see
so many people doing these days which is
making up a person's position and then
attacking the non position right so that
I talk about liberal clairvoyance where
a lot of the left believes that if you
state even a little bit of your position
oh I know why you hold that position
because you secretly just like this and
you're for that terrible thing that's so
in this idiom one of the things is is
that I look at very smart people I think
Glenn Greenwald is a very smart guy like
a lot of stuff he's done I think Reza
aslam could be very impressive and what
happens with these folks is is that they
strong in repeatedly and they try to
find the most powerful argument for
their for their readership and you look
at Sam and Sam whatever you think his
faults may be is frequently trying to
steal man somebody who is strong Manning
his position and that is the cinah qua
non of that's the ante to get into the
the higher-level conversations and I
know I'm going to take a tremendous
amount of guff on Twitter for that but
that's what I'm signed up for because I
believe that fundamentally it's not just
about attacking your opponent's position
sometimes I'll steal me on somebody's
positional say you know what I don't
think they had the best version of that
but now that I see what they may be
saying
maybe I'm even moved and I think that
it's really important to sort of extend
that as a courtesy as a grace what do
you do though when that courtesy is not
extended back to you repeatedly so
without getting into Glenn and Reza who
I think most of my audience knows
they're they're bad intentions I mean I
could even think of other examples where
just in the last couple days you know I
saw Judd Apatow and Sarah Silverman both
of them I really like Judds from the
same town as me when same high school I
like both of their work
I saw them tweeting about how Simon &
Schuster should get rid of Milo's book
now that would these are people who were
comedians that are supposed to be
getting to the edge and crossing it and
write edgy and all of this stuff and I
say I tweeted at them and I said you
know I love I've Milo coming on a couple
weeks I'd love to have you guys sit down
a conversation I didn't mean it as a
debate I'm not attacking I like Milo I
like Judd I like Sarah although not they
didn't respond to me and I suspect that
they won't respond to me but that does
make our job as people willing to extend
the the fig leaf a little more the fig
leaf the fig leaf yeah I was they all
branch with the olive branch the fig
leaf that sang us but I was I was going
to the big leaf for some reason but for
those of us that are willing to extend
that willing to have those conversations
willing to to do the intellectual work
to make the world better if it's not
handed back to you and I'm not I'm
giving a bit of a stretch with sure
position on the two of them maybe
they've responded to me while we're
talking right now but it does make our
work a little bit harder right well
let's try to steal man their position
which is a sign of good faith I think
that in part we haven't pushed out the
language we haven't pushed out the
toolkit and as a result everybody is
fumbling around with language that was
barely adequate in the 1980s it totally
doesn't make sense now and I'm not
positive that all of these people will
stay where they are I think that it's
quite possible that when we stop
focusing just on the intellectual and of
course I'm guilty of intellectualizing
everything but we start to come more
into contact with our own humanity and
pushing out some of the empathy and
emotion when I was on Sam's podcast for
example
he started talking about the beauty of
the poetry of Rumi and the the call to
prayer as being one of the most
beautiful songs you know the one hears
all the time in the Middle East which is
you know central to Islam yeah and so
horrible I think I've been called a
prayer yeah it's probably I'm extremely
moved but yeah I heard you say that I
thought pretty obnoxious in the middle
of day four times and all it's just no
we had have a different reaction I lived
in Jerusalem for a couple of years but
what I what I find is is that when we
show that we are empathic that we
understand you know Reza's in a tough
spot and that's hard for me to say
because I really don't like the way he
savages but he's in a tough spot and you
know Glenn Greenwald probably thinks at
some level that he's doing the right
thing and I'm pretty unhappy with the
biasness of some of those arguments but
I find that when I extend a certain
amount of just I muster any grace I can
to listen and to not react once people
feel a level of security in the
conversation they say you know I can
climb down from these battle positions I
thought you were saying this and so I
had to make this move I don't think
you're going to get everybody that way
but I think what part of what the
problem is is that we have to be more
willing to be emotionally vulnerable
it's not the easiest thing for a
middle-aged hard-charging you know male
but I'm trying and I'm trying to do it
on Twitter and I'm finding that I'm able
to say things they're quite difficult
with so far a minimal amount of blowback
in part by just being slower on the draw
not thinking about these as enemies
thinking that we are in some confused
state and that it's the language and the
impoverished nature of the language
that's keeping us trapped here so I'm up
for a good fight if I'm really looking
at the enemy but some of these people
like you were saying about Sarah
Silverman right she's making some bad
calls in my opinion and I just think the
world
of some of some of the comedy and the
insight and and the decency and the
bravery so something has gone wrong and
I think it's up to us in part not to
fight it out but to try to figure out
well what went wrong logically yeah well
I mean that's exactly why I even phrased
the tweet in a specific way where I
didn't say debate I said conversation
because I wouldn't make it a debate I
think at the end of the day Milo and
Judd and and Sarah could all sit down
and actually be okay I really do even if
they don't agree on every political this
or that well this is one of the reasons
that I was so excited to come here
because I forget what the original title
of Casablanca was but like everybody
comes to Rick's or something like that
and I feel like strangely this
particular home studio is the crossroads
of this new emerging sensibility which
is that you have a lot of people on some
of whom should be you know allied some
of whom should be antagonistic and what
you're doing is you're providing a
substrate where it is safe to hash some
of these things out now people are going
to interpret what's going on here very
different oh my god yeah Milo and siRNA
which you know he's gone completely
crazy all right right wing yeah but I
don't think that's what's happening I
think that what's happening is is that
the world is going to wake up to the
fact that we're having an inauthentic
conversation and this is the germ of a
new way of being which dovetails with
older ways of being that have been lost
you might say that this very room is the
tits prudent all of the thing you might
say that I can't get away with it I
might say X I know what the hell I'm
talking about there you go
well it's been a pleasure to talk to you
of course and I got a whole bunch more
here but we'll do this again how about
that love - all right thanks for having
us
on that note you can check out more of
Eric's work well you know we'll do we'll
put his answer to the edge question
we're going to link to it right down
below and can I pick out your website
you said it was a throwback so yeah
about some I think I think well maybe my
Twitter feed or he's on the Twitter it's
just at Eric Weinstein right at Eric our
Weinstein at Eric our Weinstein and
thanks for watching we'll do it again
next week
you
[Music]